Hallo, Stefan. Wir stehen wieder vor dem Salon. Und bevor wir eintreten, wollen wir aber noch ein bisschen über die Lage sprechen, denn es passiert so viel. Man ist auf der einen Seite froh, dass man nicht täglich sich dazu äußern muss, dass wir jetzt auch Zeit haben, dann Ende des Monats wieder die großen Bögen zu betrachten. Aber zugleich muss ich sagen, beängstigt mich doch sehr, wie belizistisch viele Leute gerade unterwegs sind. Fast hat man den Eindruck, bei Twitter und auch sonst wo sind Leute in so einen Gaming-Modus eingestiegen, in dem sie jetzt diesen Krieg beobachten und mitunter auch dann jubeln, es sind wieder drei russische Panzer getroffen worden oder so. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, ganz klar ist, dass Putin der Aggresso ist und so weiter und so fort. Aber das sollte uns jetzt nicht dazu anhalten, dass wir zum einen in so einen merkwürdigen Chauvinismus verfallen und verfallen in einen Belizismus, der dann so aussieht, dass man jetzt einfach nur noch ja in einem Gaming-Modus das Ganze betrachtet, was dann nämlich tatsächlich ausblendet, dass da ja auch Menschen sterben, dass da junge Männer von Putin an die Front geschickt werden.
Auch in der Ukraine.
Ja, und dass wir es jetzt von beiden Seiten eigentlich mit Leuten zu tun haben, die sich bekämpfen, die keine Entscheidungsgewalt über diesen Krieg haben, die jetzt da mitziehen, die zum großen Teil auch ideologisch verblendet sein werden, dass sie das tun, die keine andere Wahl haben. Und das ist eigentlich sehr dramatisch zu sehen, was da passiert. Ich finde auch, dass man eigentlich sagen müsste, wer in der Ukraine nicht kämpfen will, der soll bitte auch ausreisen können. Ich finde es auch ganz erstaunlich, dass wir da wenig Stimmen in Deutschland zu hören, die genau das fordern. Denn es ist doch ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass wir zum einen Leute haben, die schon von toxischer Männlichkeit reden, sobald jemand eine Currywurst isst. Und zum anderen ist man jetzt aber an so einem Punkt, wo man sagt, ja, ist ja toll, dass die da kämpfen. Das ist ja alles alles genau richtig. Und man muss jetzt mal sich auch vorstellen, was das bedeutet, wenn wir da brennende Panzer sehen. Das bedeutet, dass da Leute ganz elendig verrecken in diesen Dingern. Und wir müssen auch da wirklich noch mal unterscheiden zwischen denen, die Krieg führen, und jenen, die da einfach in irgendeiner Weise mitziehen müssen. Also wenn ich jetzt mal an die russische Seite denke, dann wissen wir, dass es in Russland seit Jahr und Tag keine freie Presse mehr gibt und dass die Menschen einer permanenten Propaganda ausgesetzt sind. Das heißt, wir können jetzt, selbst wenn die Soldaten da aus freien Stücken in den Krieg ziehen, nicht davon sprechen, dass die das wirklich freiwillig tun. Sie wissen eigentlich nicht, was sie tun. Und zugleich würde ich auch sagen, wir dürfen nicht jetzt anfangen, ukrainische Soldaten zu glorifizieren. Man kann die Solidarität aussprechen und man kann das auch in gewisser Weise bewundern, dass sie da mit irgendwelchen Mitteln versuchen, sich dem entgegenzustellen. Aber zugleich muss man auch sehen, was das für eine Menschheitskatastrophe ist. Wenn so viele Menschen sterben, es geht auch am Ende nur um ein Stück Land. Und da kann man auch eigentlich mal einen richtigen Feminismus in Anschlag bringen, der laut wird und der sagt, man ist dagegen, dass Männer in den Tod geschickt werden, dass sie Soldaten sein müssen. Man kann laut werden gegen dieses patriotische Geschwätz. Und das vermisse ich von den sonst immer Woken.
Ganz deiner Meinung. Ich habe ja in meinen aktuellen Fernsehmomenten auch schon dafür plädiert, militärisch das Ding beendet zu erklären und zu sagen, der Krieg hört jetzt einfach auf, weil sich in der Ukraine keiner mehr wehrt. Also das ist ja ein bisschen wieder wie bei Corona. Corona geht so los und die ersten drei Wochen sind erst mal so happening. Wir machen nur schulfrei bis Osterfehlend. Dann plötzlich sind es zwei Jahre und so ist das ja hier auch. Die Welt hat vorhin gerade vor einer Viertelstunde oder so so ein Tweet gehabt. Dieses Paar heiratet inmitten der ukrainischen Kriegszone. Dann soll man den Link anklicken und dann hängt noch ein Bild an, wie er in Uniform, sie auch quasi in Uniform, aber schon sozusagen mit der Ausreise beschäftigt. Aber noch so ein Schleier im Haar, damit man es ein bisschen erkennt, dass es noch Zeit sein soll. Und dann küssen sie sich ja. Und das ist der totale Kitsch. Wir kommen ja gleich auf Alexander Kluge zu sprechen. Da wird ja auch in der Zeit gefragt, gibt es eine neue Ästhetisierung des Krieges? Und anstatt Ja oder Nein zu sagen, sagt Alexander Kluge einfach, das ist genau das, was ich so gefährlich finde. Und das ist genau richtig. Das ist genau die richtige Antwort. Diese Kitschhaftigkeit, mit der wir hier gerade, keine Ahnung, morgens Deutschlandfunk ruft irgendwo an, die 100 Milliarden. Ja, ja, wir müssen ja auch verteidigungsfähig sein. Gegen was denn? Also es ist auf aller Ebene total Banane. Und diese Verherrlichung des Krieges in der Hinsicht, dass man jetzt den Ukrainern Tapferkeit unterschiebt, wo doch einfach nur die Ansage ist, du bist unter 60, du darfst hier nicht ausreisen. Was dann nicht passiert, auf der anderen Seite, diese Texte über und wieder kam ein Kind ohne Begleitung, die Telefonnummer eilig noch so auf den Unterarm geschrieben, wo man dann anrufen soll, weil in Slowenien gibt es wohl irgendwo Bekannte und Verwandte und wie auch immer. Das versteht niemand. Ursula von der Leyen, wir kommen im Salon heute auch auf Texte zurück. Ich habe das erste Mal, denke ich mir, du hast vielleicht denselben Text gelesen wie ich, Adam Two's Chartbook 91, MMT und Russia.
Ich habe ihn gelesen, aber nicht mitgebracht.
Okay, ich habe ihn mit. Okay, dann können wir nachher drüber sprechen. Denn auf der Ebene findet ja der Krieg statt, wirtschaftlich. Viele Leute sind mir überrascht, jetzt 100 Milliarden. Ukraine ist doppelt so groß wie das deutsche Bundesgebiet, mehr als doppelt so groß. Und es sind jetzt 200.000 russische Soldaten, die was mit dem Land machen sollen, besetzen und dann dauerhaft da irgendwas sehr völlig Banane, dass sowas funktioniert. In Deutschland hat man jetzt 100 Milliarden mobilisiert für die Bundeswehr. Was heißt denn das jetzt, dass wir dafür 10.000 Panzer kaufen oder was? Deutschland kann man militärisch materiell nicht verteidigen. Das haben wir gesehen, als es nur 3 Tage Regen gab, die an ungünstiger Stelle fielen und plötzlich hieß es ja, also der Schaden sind jetzt 60 Milliarden, es ist auch der größte Schaden seit der Nachkriegszeit. So durch Regen. Wenn man jetzt sagt, ok, es ist nicht Regen, sondern es hagelt jetzt Bomben und zwar gezielt, also nicht durch Zufall, Wettereignis und es war halt der falsche Ort und so, sondern das wird gezielt, liegt Deutschland in Schutt und Asche. Und da kann man überhaupt gar nichts dagegen machen. Entweder wir haben ein großes Bündnis, das uns schützt oder eben nicht. Und dieses Szenario, also das ist völlig bescheuert.
Ich kann das gar nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Also man hat zum Teil nicht nur den Eindruck, die sind im 20. Jahrhundert, sondern mitunter sogar im 19. Jahrhundert, dass die glauben, dass es jetzt noch mal so, dass da sich die Armeen gegenüberstehen und dann guckt man, wer übrig bleibt. Selbst wenn Deutschland seit zehn Jahren das NATO-Zwei-Prozent-Ziel über erfüllen würde, würde das ja an der aktuellen Situation nichts ändern. Da würde man ja nicht sagen prima, wir haben ja Panzer, wir fahren jetzt auf und versuchen da jetzt ins Gefecht zu gehen, sondern wir wissen, was dann kommt. Das ist genau der Atomkrieg. Und ich bin so froh, dass die Leute, gerade aus der Medienbranche, so Niels Minkmaar, Döpfner usw. und so fort, dass die nicht regieren. Also man muss sich das ja mal vorstellen, wenn das jetzt unsere Politiker wären, die entscheiden müssten, dann wären wir ja in einer Katastrophe. Also Baerbock hat ja ein Tweet geschrieben, wo sie sagte, wir müssen einen kühlen Kopf bewahren, so sehr es uns das Herz zerreißt. Das ist genau das, was ich von Politik erwarte, diesen kühlen Kopf bewahren und sich nicht hinreißen lassen, während sich alle gerade hinreißen lassen zu irgendwelchen Aussagen. Wenn ich dann an den von der Böll-Stiftung denke, diesen Ralf Fuchs, der sagt, jetzt mal effektive Waffen zur Verfügung stellen, den Ukrainern, das suggeriert ja auch dann immer, ja, noch ein paar Schüsse, und dann haben wir wirklich gewonnen. Es ist so eigenartig und man muss sich dann auch, weil du gerade Adam Toos schon erwähnt hast, Adam Toos im Stern-Podcast anhören, wo er dann sagt, als diese Sanktionen durch die Zentralbank kamen, als da wirklich dann nicht nur Swift, sondern man zu ganz anderen Waffen greiften, als er das las, da hatte er Angst. Also das sagt er auch in dem Podcast so. Das ist schon was, wenn ein Historiker, der ganz gut weiß, wie Konflikte entstehen, wie was eskaliert, sagt, er hatte Angst. Also wir müssen auch da sehen, da gibt es Eskalationsstufen und das kann sehr, sehr problematisch werden dann. Und ich empfehle das sehr, sich mal anzuhören, was Toos da sagt. Und ich würde auch mal bitten, dass man ein bisschen aus diesem Hollywood-Modus rauskommt. Also dieser Stefan Anpalagian fällt mir jetzt gerade ein. Der hat dann getwittert, ich hätte niemals gedacht, dass der Titel Leader of the Free World eines Tages an den ukrainischen Präsidenten gehen würde. Und ist das jetzt der Modus, in dem wir die ganze Zeit diesen Krieg bewerten? Und dann können wir noch fragen, wann werden die Avengers gemeinsam mit der NATO, Thanos und Putin besiegen? Es ist ganz grausam. Und ich würde auch mal gerne wissen, was ist mit all diesen Phrasen gemeint? Carolin Imke hat einen Artikel geschrieben, da heißt es, Menschenrechte und Demokratie sind nicht nebensächlich und nachgeordnet. Okay, wie viele glauben wollten. Sie sind nichts, was sich nur willkürlich und partiell schützen ließe. Sie gelten nicht nur manchmal, wenn es nichts kostet, sondern immer. Was bedeutet das jetzt? Machen wir eine wertegeleitete Außenpolitik? Das heißt, da müssen wir jetzt da in Russland einmarschieren und riskieren den dritten Weltkrieg. Wir haben eigentlich, ich empfehle dann nochmal diesen Text von Herfried Münkler über den Truppenabzug in Afghanistan aus dem letzten Jahr, der in den Blättern erschienen ist. Wir haben eigentlich gesehen, diese wertegeleitete Außenpolitik hat uns ein Fiasco nach dem anderen eingebracht. Und jetzt würde es uns tatsächlich noch ein nukleares Fiasco einbringen. Das ist ganz schrecklich zu sehen. Und diese Ohnmacht ist ja furchtbar. Wir sehen ja gerade, wie machtlos man sein kann. Beim Virus hieß es schon immer, ja, wir sind so machtlos gegenüber der Natur. Nee, wir waren extrem mächtig. Wir haben Masken, Abstand, Impfungen, Lockdowns und so weiter. Wir hatten unglaublich viel Macht gegen dieses Virus in der Hand. Aber hier sind wir tatsächlich, also wir als Normalbürger, unglaublich machtlos. Und das ist auch beängstigend und auch eine schreckliche Lage. Aber das muss man mal eingestehen und damit dann in irgendeiner Weise zurechtkommen und zum anderen dann auch ein Plädoyer für den Frieden.
Daraus ableiten. Genau, Frieden, also ich weiß auch noch nicht genau, wie man es kommunizieren soll, aber Kriege enden mit Kapitulation. Die Frage ist nur, treibt man es bis zum Ende oder antizipiert man vorher und sagt, was wir ja immer gesagt haben, die Ukraine wäre einer russischen Invasion nicht gewachsen. So, jetzt ging das aber los, jetzt betteln sich alle um die Eskalationsdominanz, wie man so schön sagt. Jeder möchte irgendwie die Oberhand zurück gewinnen. Man weiß nicht genau, auf welcher Ebene wird jetzt gekämpft eigentlich. Es ist die militärische oder die mediale Auseinandersetzung, weil dann sind irgendwie auch alle so im Krieg. Auch die, die du gerade so vorgelesen hast, die Namen, die sehen sich ja alle irgendwie so involviert. Völlig ausgeblendet und mit völlig meine ich, es ist zumindest übertrieben krass, wie wenig das beobachtet wird, was hier ökonomisch gerade wirklich passiert. Wir werden es bei Tuis nachher nochmal lesen. Ich finde, das ist wirklich auch ein Vergeltungsschlag auf eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung. Die Tragweite ist uns alle nicht bewusst. Die Russen haben jetzt ihr 15 Jahre Gefängnisandrohungsgesetz bei Fake News über den Krieg, was jegliche Thematisierung meint. Was bedeutet, dass ARD und ZDF ihre Berichterstattung aus Russland komplett eingestellt haben und auf TikTok, nicht mal auf TikTok, da kann man noch ein Video hochladen. Das sagt schon einiges, Twitter und Facebook sind sowieso blockiert. Wer wirklich glaubt, dass das in Russland selber jetzt nichts ändert oder weil es morgen noch nicht sichtbar ist. Also das sind jetzt Prozesse, die laufen jetzt einfach Wochen und Monate, die sind aber auch wirklich tiefgreifend. Und die Angst, die russischer Männer jetzt eingezogen zu werden und dann sozusagen mit Waffe am Kopf in den Krieg erpresst zu werden, ist immens. Das wird auch ein bisschen übersehen.
Ja, wir haben nämlich auch dort junge, moderne Menschen. Wir haben da LGBT-Communities und ich finde das so schlimm, dass man jetzt wirklich so eine Russophobie zum Teil verspürt, dass Restaurants in Berlin schlechte Bewertungen bei Google bekommen, weil sie russisch sind, dass sich jetzt jeder bekennen soll. Das ist für mich wirklich so ein Gratismut, der der Gratismut derer, die nichts riskieren. Wir haben diesen Cancel Culture Begriff oft auch verlacht, aber es findet auch so was wie Cancel Culture momentan statt. Ich würde erst mal einen Sonderfall sehen, das ist der Dirigent Gergiev von den Münchner Philharmonikern. Das muss man etwas anders bewerten.
Der geht in die Oligarchen-Ecke.
Genau, Gergiev ist von Anfang an auf Putins Seite und ist nicht jetzt irgendwie auffällig geworden, sondern das wissen wir seit zehn Jahren, wie der tickt und welche Einstellungen der da hat. Jetzt ist der Mann Chefdirigent gewesen der Münchner Philharmoniker. Da hat er drei Aufgaben. Einmal den Klangkörper pflegen, zweitens Pflichtdirigate übernehmen und drittens, das ist das Wichtigste, die Münchner Philharmoniker zu repräsentieren. Da hätte man sich, als man ihn anstellte, 2015 oder 2016, wann das war, schon sich fragen können, ist das der richtige Mann, um uns zu repräsentieren? Und die Antwort wäre schon damals nein gewesen. Dass man den jetzt rauskickt, weil er sich nicht distanziert, ja was erwartet man, der hat sich nie distanziert, warum sollte der sich gerade jetzt distanzieren? Das ist einfach nur Schadensbegrenzung, aber den Schaden hat man selbst angerichtet. Ich würde aber das als Sonderfall betrachten, aber wir können jetzt nicht von jedem russischen Künstler, der irgendwo einen Gastauftritt hat, irgendwo singt oder sonst was macht, erwarten, dass er sich bekennt zu irgendetwas oder dass wir jemanden abstrafen, weil er mal irgendwo mit Putin gesehen wurde. Denn wir müssen auch eines begreifen, das sind Leute, die vielleicht auch in einem gewissen Sachzwang operieren. Ja, da sind auch Leute, die haben Familie in Russland und die können jetzt nicht so einfach wie unsereins sagen, der Putin ist furchtbar. Uns macht das nichts aus, wir werden da keine Repression erleiden müssen und wir können auch nicht diese Form der Bekenntnisse immer einfordern. Das machen wir im Übrigen laufend nicht. Also wie viele Stars treten ständig irgendwo in aller Welt auf bei Diktatoren und sonst was und singen da, da machen wir das nicht. Und jetzt können wir nicht da plötzlich, weil wir Russland als Feind sehen und dann nicht mehr die russische Regierung, sondern wirklich Russland, können wir das nicht überall einfordern. Und das ist auch wieder diese Idee der Machtlosigkeit, die man nicht akzeptieren will. Und jetzt glaubt man, damit kann man jetzt mal irgendwas machen. Also jetzt versucht man noch jeder kleine Theaterintendant, irgendeine Aufführung zu verhindern oder irgendein Statement jemandem abzuringen, nur weil man eigentlich erkennen muss, wir sind gerade erstaunlich machtlos, können nur hoffen, dass Scholz, Baerbock und die anderen weiter einen Kurs halten, der die Sache nicht zum Eskalieren bringt.
Genau. Und denen fällt das schwer genug. Wir lesen nachher so eine kleine Chronologie in der FAZ, die hat es mal aufgeschrieben, unter Aussparung von allem, was interessant ist, nämlich dem, was in der EU-Kommission vor sich ging, wo man ja die eigentlichen Ideen alle hatte. Wir haben uns ja verabredet, vorher noch über Alexander Kluge zu sprechen. Da hat er in der Zeit ein Interview gegeben an Peter Neumann. Das Wort hat dann übertitelt, mit Sieger ist nicht, wer die Schlacht gewinnt. Na gut. Mir sind drei Sätze darin wahnsinnig wichtig. Zum einen, und jetzt kann man ja wirklich das ganze Ding mal eine Ebene höher heben. Im Sinne von, ach ja, gut, der Böhmermann twittert, Putin ist der Böse. Also sehen wir alle, dass Putin irgendwie der Böse ist. Klar, Putin ist der Böse. Er nennt sich der Aggressor. Er hat die Eskalationsdominanz, er hat die Atombomben und so weiter. Alles mal eingepreist. Aber das, was ja eigentlich zu verhandeln ist, ist ja ein Krieg. Und wie ist der eigentlich einzuschätzen? Und da sagt Alexander Kluge so mittendrin, der Krieg ist ein Dämon, den man nicht beherrschen kann. Im Krieg ist nichts entscheidbar. Was bedeutet, der Krieg selbst ist hier der Akteur gerade, so wie das Virus ein Akteur war. Oder auch mein Lieblingsthema, die Demografie. Da kann man dann gar nichts gegen machen. Da gibt es dann nicht die eine Seite und die andere, sondern beide haben mit dem Krieg zu tun. Klar, wir können jetzt irgendwie beobachten, wir wissen nicht, wie viel Fanfiction da drinsteckt von westlicher Journalistenseite auch. Putin wollte das ja eigentlich innerhalb von drei Tagen alles klären, so wie bei der Grimm. Gelang ihm nicht. Jetzt hat Putin so einen Krieg an der Backe, genau wie wir. Der eskaliert nämlich einfach selber vor sich hin. Und jetzt muss Putin auch überlegen, ich bin jetzt hier oberster Feldherr, was mache ich jetzt mit diesem Krieg? Ich wollte das ja auch nicht. Ich bin ja auch von neuen Zart-Sachen gestellt. Und wir wissen aber alle, so richtig raus aus dem Krieg kommt man nicht. Schon in der Diplomatie ist der Gesichtsverlust ja eine echte Bürde, mit der man die eine immer quält von Entscheidung zu Entscheidung und so hangeln sich jetzt alle an so Entscheidungsketten entlang. Und jetzt sagt aber Kluge, auch so mit Rückgriff auf Klausowitz und so, nee, im Krieg ist nichts entscheidbar. Der Krieg selber eskaliert und das fällt natürlich irgendwie schwer, aber das muss man dann auch erstmal wirklich anerkennen und auch beachten. Bei allem, was man schreibt, wenn man jetzt forderunglos wird, was wie Putin sich verhalten sollte als oberster Entscheider. Wem gilt das dann? Glaubt man dann Putin liest da mit oder gilt das so in der eigenen Twitter-Follower-Schaft, der eigenen Leserschaft, so ja, wir sammeln jetzt uns alle mal hinter ein Bekenntnis, aber dann wollen wir das auch hören, egal wie inhaltlich sinnlos und wiederholend es dann eigentlich ist und dann auch wirklich nichts aussagen. Also diese Anerkennung des Krieges selbst als Akteur, er sagt jetzt Dämon, das ist natürlich immer so eine Wortwahl, die so ein bisschen, ja, was ist denn denn Dämon, aber der Krieg selbst als Protagonist, den jetzt alle an der Backe haben.
Ein 90-jähriger Schriftsteller und Filmemacher, der eine enorme historische Erfahrung erst mal durch seine eigene Biografie mitbringt und der sich immer genau mit diesen großen Fragen auseinandergesetzt hat, der also die Geschichte tatsächlich studiert hat, studiert hat, welche Konflikte schwielen, wo, warum. Und das ist das bemerkenswert, dass man jetzt hier jemand hat, der in einer ganz anderen Weise, nämlich auf einer Abstraktionsebene, gleich über das sprechen kann, was ja so wenig geschieht. Also ich möchte auch gerne mal in einer Talkshow erleben, dass man in dieser Grundsätzlichkeit darüber spricht und nicht im Gaming-Modus verfährt oder du hast es ja auch im Fernsehpodcast gesagt, dass man erstmal so eine 40-minütige Bekenntnis-Rhetorik an den Taten legt. Also man muss jetzt nicht bei jedem Satz, den man sagt, nochmal betonen, schlimm, was Putin macht. Das haben jetzt alle begriffen und da wird jetzt auch niemand sitzen, der sagen, nee, ist aber eigentlich super. Und da kann man dann direkt mal auf ein anderes Abstraktionsniveau gehen. Und das ist ganz entscheidend und das ist auch, wofür Künstler dann da sind, dass sie so was natürlich können. Was mir sehr gut gefallen hat, ist, dass er sagt, es gibt nicht einen einzigen Wert in der Welt, sei er materiell oder ideell, der Krieg rechtfertigt. Das heißt nicht Pazifismus. Ich bin kein Friedensprediger. Aber der Krieg ist unberechenbar. Hier hat man wieder so eine Subjektivierung des Krieges. Das Einzige, was absolut unbeherrschbar bleibt, ist Krieg.
Ja, genau. Der Krieg entscheidet selber, so ein bisschen was er macht. Umso mehr teilnehmen, umso wirrer wird es. Und dann, ich habe es ja eben schon vorgelesen, gibt es eine neue Ästhetik des Krieges? Das ist genau das, was ich so gefährlich finde. Da muss jeder in sich gehen. Da nützt es kein öffentliches Bekenntnis, sondern muss sich jeder selber fragen. Oh Gott, hier tauchen gerade Paul Ronzheimer Tweets aus. Er mit Helm und Schutzweste und so weiter.
Stichwort Ästhetisierung des Krieges.
Richtig, ganz genau. Die Ästhetisierung des Krieges. Wenn man selber teilnimmt, mitdenkend oder vielleicht sogar mitschreibt, zum Beispiel mit der wie auch immer oder am Gespräch, am Küchentisch. Wenn man das, was man sagt, führt das wirklich zu einem Ende des Krieges oder will man nur Tipps geben, wie der Westen gewinnen kann oder wie man Putin am besten demütigt oder sowas. Also ist man ganz ehrlich mit sich und will ein Ende des Krieges oder will man den Krieg nur in eine Richtung lenken, die so die eigene ist, also so Team und dann sagt man zu wem man gehört. Und das ist doch eine Herausforderung, der sich ganz viele mal stellen sollten, weil ich finde es unglaublich, dass gerade überhaupt gar nicht darüber gesprochen wird, dass die Ukraine jetzt auch einfach kapitulieren könnte. Unter der Maßgabe, gut Putin, du wolltest diesen Krieg, du hast ihn. Alle ökonomischen Regime, die gerade installiert sind, bleiben in Kraft und werden auch nachgedreht, je nachdem was beobachtet ist. Denn das Ziel ist klar, damit darf man auf der globalen Bühne nicht durchkommen. Aber die Menschenleben werden zumindest gerettet. Also Kampfhandlungen werden eingestellt. Alle Ukrainer legen ihre Waffen nieder, dürfen aber auch das Land verlassen, wenn sie es denn wollen. Wir wissen, aus Richtung Ukraine ist jeder Gang gehen Westen in Richtung Sehnsuchtsgebiete. Und das kann man sich dann gerade aussuchen.
Das muss man auch sich klar machen. Da müssen jetzt Männer ein Land verteidigen, das sie eigentlich auch gern verlassen würden, wenn sie jetzt hier die Chance hätte zu arbeiten. Das ist jetzt nicht, dass da bei allen die Vaterlandsliebe so hoch steht. Und deswegen muss man, glaube ich, in ganz anderer Weise Politik und Weltpolitik denken, weil man damit auch ein Signal, ein sehr wirkmächtiges an China senden kann. Insofern, als man ihnen sagt, naja, also wenn ihr jetzt euch das ein oder andere noch einverleiben wollt, dann wisst ihr ja, dass wir jetzt nicht gleich in den dritten Weltkrieg deshalb gehen. Aber dann ist das ein finanzieller Krieg und der kann sehr, sehr unangenehm werden. Guckt mal, wie das in Russland gerade läuft.
Genau.
Denn die Dollarhegemonie ist nach wie vor da und Reichtum nutzt nur etwas.
Die wird ja gerade nochmal gestärkt dadurch. Es gibt ja sehr viele Profiteure, auch auf westlicher Richtung, gerade LNG und so weiter. Wo kriegen wir unser Gas jetzt her? Na ja, es sind halt die neuen Produzenten und Lieferanten, die lange suchten nach Abnehmen. Jetzt haben sie endlich wieder Absatzmärkte.
Und Reichtum ist etwas sehr Relatives, beziehungsweise ist immer auch darauf angewiesen, dass es anerkannt wird. Also wenn ich sage, ich bin reich und du aber sagst ja, Wolfgang, ich akzeptiere aber deine Schecks nicht, dann habe ich ein Problem.
Das werden wir nachher mit Adam Toos mal genau studieren. Wir hören mal jetzt einen kurzen Autokommentar von Enzo. Ich habe ihn nochmal zusammengeschnippelt auf anderthalb Minuten. Der ist vom 23. April und dann kann man die Migrationslage, nämlich jetzt, wo wir wissen, wie es sich historisch entfaltet hat, die letzten zehn Tage, kann man das nämlich nochmal einordnen, was vorher so als, das kann ja auch auf der Ebene crazy werden. Wir wissen ja, wie Fluchtbewegungen Europa und Deutschland durcheinander rütteln.
Alle G20-Länder leiten an dramatischen, alternden Gesellschaften. Das heißt, wir in Deutschland konkurrieren mit all diesen Ländern, inklusive Schwergewichten wie Japan, den USA, dann demnächst auch China, um mehr oder weniger qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte. Und jetzt maßen wir uns an, als könnten wir demnächst nach kanadischem Vorbild uns die migrantischen Fachkräfte selbst aussuchen. Als würden da Top-Experten aus der gesamten Welt nur darauf warten, nach Deutschland reisen zu können. Wenn wir mit so vielen anderen Ländern konkurrieren, wird das nicht funktionieren. Und diese Arroganz wird uns dann ganz schnell auf die Füße fallen. Aber das wird in dieser Debatte einfach völlig erkannt, wie schnell das dann noch gehen kann. Das Leben wäre leider in sehr stabilen Zeiten und die Sicherheit der Ukraine wird bedroht. Niemand weiß jetzt, was Russland tun wird. Also was mich da wundert, Stand 23. Jahrzehnte ist, niemand fragt sich, was die Menschen tun werden, wenn es zur groß angelegten Inversion kommt. Also das kommt irgendwie gerade auch nicht so richtig vor. Nämlich ist dann die Frage, werden dann Tausende bis Hunderttausende Flüchtlinge versuchen über die östlichen EU-Staaten, versuchen nach Europa einzuwandeln, also in die EU-Länder. Und wie gehen wir dann mit denen um? Gehen wir dann mit denen um, wie mit den Irakern und den Afghanen und lassen die östlichen EU-Mitglieder einen hohen Grenzzaun bauen?
Tja, am 23. Februar haben wir uns das noch so gefragt. Jetzt sehen wir, wir schenken allen Bahntickets, sie dürfen sich ihr Land aussuchen, in das sie fahren wollen, nach Deutschland, nach Portugal, nach Spanien. Wir wissen mittlerweile auch, 2015 gab es so und so viel Grenzüberschritte, es hat ganz Europa rumgerüttelt, es hat jahrelang gebraucht und fast eine Kanzlerschaft gekostet. Innerhalb der letzten Woche kamen mehr Menschen in die Europäische Union als im ganzen Jahr 2015. Die Hälfte davon sind Kinder im Schulalter. Relativ wenig Männer aus den genannten Gründen. Die Polen sind besonders aufgeschlossen, obwohl dort mittlerweile mehr Menschen angekommen sind in Bezug auf die eigene Bevölkerung. Also doppelt so viel wie im ganzen Jahr 2015 in Deutschland. Also das ist eine richtige Migrationswelle. Nur die Polen kennen ja die Ukrainer. Die Ukrainer sind nämlich in Polen das, was die Polen in England sind und die Türken bei uns. Das sind die, die einfach die Grundlast am Laufen halten, die den ganzen Dienstleistungssektor abdecken, wo man relativ zügig unqualifizierte Leute für alles Mögliche einsetzen kann, weil die einfach sich auch wirklich willig zeigen, anzukommen in solchen Ländern. So, und jetzt läuft auf der Ebene da auch eine große Lotterie. Sehr viele Länder brauchen gerade Nachwuchs, insbesondere Deutschland. So, jetzt hat sich zwar Giffey schon aufgeregt, dass schon wieder alle nur in Berlin ankommen, aber ja, das ist für sie so ein Verwaltungsproblem. Volkswirtschaftlich ist das natürlich ganz anders zu betrachten. In der Hinsicht ist das zwar ein ganz schlimmer Krieg, der da läuft, aber es ist nicht allzu zynisch, sich die ganzen Profiteure jetzt mal anzuschauen. Also volkswirtschaftlich, wir haben ja auch beim Bau 20% der Azubis in Hamburg auf dem Bau sind junge Menschen aus der 2015er Flüchtlingswelle. Die Amerikaner haben jetzt technisch das LNG-Frecking-Zeug da hingekriegt und wollen das Zeug irgendwie verkaufen, kriegen jetzt auch ihre Landungshafen da in Wilhelmshafen und so weiter. Also man kann hier tatsächlich jetzt so Länder wie Russland ökonomisch einfach richtig rausnehmen. Und wenn man jetzt mal mit ein, zwei Jahren Rückblick auf diesen Krieg oder jetzt auf Februar, März 2022 schaut, wird man sich auch irgendwann mal so fragen, wieso mussten da für so viele Leute sterben? Warum musste das sein? Also die Interessen lagen doch irgendwie dann doch ziemlich klar da, sowohl auf elementarer, was will die ukrainische Familie in Frieden leben? In Westeuropa? Cool, wir fahren sofort. Russland ist halt jetzt so ein Despoten da ausgeliefert, der versucht, mit so krassen Gesetzen das irgendwie noch alles zusammenzuhalten, aber von dem wir gar nicht genau wissen, inwieweit er noch irgendwas kontrollieren kann. Und wirtschaftlich geht ja wohl alles so jetzt in Richtung, die natürlich erstmal Anpassungsschwierigkeiten, aber dann viele neue Profiteure, Absatzmärkte, auch die sozusagen formale, also juristische Absicherung von Märkten bedeutet. Denn so wie sich die NATO gerade aufstellt, wird ja wohl so eine Gefahr erst mal demnächst nicht drohen für irgendwelche Mitgliedstaaten, sondern da kann man jetzt wieder auf geruhsames Wirtschaften die nächsten Jahrzehnte sich einstellen, ohne äußere Bedrohung. Denn auch in China, China ist ein anderes Land als Russland, in China wird man es auf den Krieg nicht ankommen lassen, auch wenn Olof Roller meint, ihm ist das System wichtiger als der Frieden. Also Qi würde lieber in dem Krieg sein System verteidigen, als im Frieden Abstriche davon nehmen. Aber so wie in Deutschland, ziemlich viel durch den Regenfall kaputt gehen kann, was echt teuer wird, kann auch in China ziemlich viel durch den Krieg kaputt gehen. Das ist in der Ukraine einfach anders. Und deswegen wird da auch gerade dieser Krieg geführt. Da gibt es relativ wenig zu verteidigen. Da ist vieles schon verloren. Und seien wir ehrlich, die Ukraine hat uns überhaupt null interessiert, dass man alleine durch den Grenzübertritt nach Polen sein familiäres Einkommen verdreifacht statistisch. Und wenn man noch ein bisschen weitergeht nach Deutschland, sogar verneunfacht. Das sind einfach Realitäten.
Da sollte man sich nichts einreden lassen von Norbert Röttgen. Wir haben uns doch viel aufgestellt, um den Ukrainern zu helfen. Das hat uns vorher nie interessiert. Und wir haben jedes Land ausgerungen und würden die Ukraine natürlich als EU-Mitglied auch gleich ausbringen, wo es nur geht. Noch einmal auf Kluge zurückkommend will ich mal diesen Satz noch zitieren, hinsichtlich der Ästhetisierung. Anstelle von Ästhetisierung muss mit voller Empathie und Emotion, dass hierfür notwendige Unterscheidungsvermögen in unseren Öffentlichkeiten geschärft werden. Ein Maschinengewehr mit Klitschko dahinter ist hingegen nichts als ein Plakat. Also diese Art der Marvel-Berichterstattung muss wirklich aufhören. Und wir müssen uns auch fragen, wenn wir in diesen absoluten Freund-Feind-Schemen denken, wie wollen wir denn überhaupt noch mal einen Frieden schließen? Also wollen wir jetzt ab sofort sagen, wir sehen Russland als unseren grundsätzlichen Rivalen an und damit auch die russische Bevölkerung? Das kann ja nicht sein. Kluge bezieht sich ja in seinen Äußerungen auch auf den westfälischen Frieden. Und diese westfälische Ordnung meint ja, dass wenn Staaten zwischenstaatliche Kriegen führen, dass sie dann auch wieder Frieden schließen können. Und dass das aber nur möglich ist, wenn man den Feind nicht diskriminiert. Das heißt, die Russen sind jetzt nicht die Orks. Das muss man hier ganz klar so sagen, auch wenn das in der FAZ so stand. Dann muss man das hier nochmal ganz klar unterstreiten.
Und zwar von Bert Kohler, dem Herausgeber der Politikseiten, dort geschrieben ist. Unglaublich. Man kann sich zu Recht darüber aufrechten.
Ja, also wenn man in diese Denkweise gerät, dann ist man in der absoluten Feindschaft angekommen und dann entmenschlicht man den Gegner. Und das darf auf keinen Fall passieren. Und das ist so fundamental und es ist so erschreckend, dass tatsächlich diese, und hier kann man mal von Narrativen sprechen, diese Narrative Einzug gehalten haben und ohne Hinterfragen immer wieder geteilt werden. Es ist, finde ich, ganz entsetzlich. Und das hätte ich tatsächlich nicht gedacht. Also mich überrascht nichts an Putin. Dem hätte ich ja alles zugetraut. Aber mich überrascht tatsächlich, wie sich Leute gerade aus den Medien, gerade Leute, die linksliberal sind, die sonst immer sehr vorsichtig sind, ob jeder auch ja das rechte Wort gesagt hat, die jetzt plötzlich in einer vollkommenen Enthemmung diese Kerbe schlagen, wo ich dachte, das ist doch eigentlich längst passé.
Ich lese hier gerade die Süddeutsche Zeitung, twittert jetzt in dem Moment, trotz Ukraine-Krieg, nach den Jusos wendet sich mit den Senioren die nächste Gruppe in der SPD gegen den Plan des Kanzlers, die Bundeswehr deutlich aufzurüsten. Also mal gucken, welche Dynamik das noch gewinnt. Mir fehlt zum Beispiel ein Text, der in diese Richtung geht, wie du es eben beschrieben hast. Putin war alles zuzutrauen. Jetzt haben wir auch gesehen, er ist total mit der Lage. Aber die Unterscheidung Putin und die Russen, und zwar so als Bevölkerung, und zwar alle, die da leben, nicht nur die Russen selbst, sondern Menschen halt. Grundsätzlich.
Heterogenes Volk oder eine heterogene Bevölkerung.
Genau, und da könnte ja die Europäische Union jetzt einfach die Ansage machen, die Aussöhnung mit dem Westen, und wir sind zu allem bereit, ist die Aufgabe des nächsten russischen Präsidenten. Und dann wüssten alle auf der Welt, also mit Putin wäre das jetzt nicht zu machen, dieses ganze ewig diplomatische Hin und Her hantieren mit, wie kriegt man das jetzt noch hin, dass er sein Gesicht nicht verliert und so. Das ist jetzt einfach abgeschlossen, mit Putin, der ist auch 70 Jahre alt, ist da nichts mehr zu gewinnen. Aber die Botschaft an alle, die Aussöhnung Russlands mit dem Westen, und zwar auf allen Ebenen, wir bieten alles an, und das muss man dann aber auch so ehrlich wie Alexander Kluge sagen, man muss diesen arabischen, ne, abarischen Punkt finden, wo das Kräfte gleichgewischt nachvollziehbar für alle gefunden werden kann. Dieses Angebot ist gemacht, allerdings nicht mit Putin, und das versteht dann, glaube ich, auch jeder in Russland, dass das, ne, das geht nicht mit Putin, aber halt mit dem Nächsten. Und dann muss man halt auf die dynamischen, und das ist dann fast wie Krieg, ja, da ist man einfach so einer Situation ausgeliefert, dann muss man einfach abwarten, was in Russland passiert. Denn was will man machen? Ja, Regime-Change in Moskau, also ist ja auch alles total absurd. Alexander Kluges hat noch einen sehr schönen Satz geschrieben, der wirklich die zwei Katastrophen und Zwanzigerjahre hier schon verklammert. Sie dürfen den Krieg gar nicht erst anfassen, denn er ist infektiös wie ein Virus. Das ist einfach perfekt. Genau so ist es. Und na ja, sei hiermit natürlich auch empfohlen, neben unseren zehn Salon-Texten.
Genau. Soll ich mal kurz sagen, was wir im Petto haben. Also wir sprechen einmal über Kampf der Nationen, wie der wirtschaftliche Wettbewerb unsere Zukunft zerstört, von Patrick Kaczmarczyk. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich den Namen völlig korrekt ausgesprochen habe. Es ist ein Buch, das uns mal aufzeigt, inwieweit die Wettbewerbsideologie zwar zu erbitterten Preiskämpfen führt, aber zu wenig Innovation und wie sich die Länder untereinander in Europa schaden. Also wenn man Europa wirklich als eine Gemeinschaft verstehen möchte und nicht einfach als einen Wirtschaftsraum, in dem erbitterte Konkurrenz herrscht, ist das ein anderer, nicht neoklassischer Blick auf die Wirtschaft. Darüber diskutieren wir gemeinsam. Außerdem habe ich ein Buch gelesen, das sehr gehypt wird, das mich aber dann doch recht enttäuscht hat, nämlich Das Recht auf Sex, Feminismus im 21. Jahrhundert von Amia Srinivasan. Ich werde einen Essay dennoch daraus etwas ausführlicher vorstellen, nämlich einen Essay über Pornografie. Und werde auch mal begründen, warum mich das ein bisschen enttäuscht hat, das Buch. Dann habe ich noch ein kleines Büchlein gefunden von Karl Kinski über die Proud Boys. Da wird mal die Geschichte der Proud Boys nachvollzogen, wer da so dahinter steckt. Das fand ich sehr erstaunlich und wird auch nochmal relevant werden, sicherlich in Amerika, denn diese Strömungen sind ja da und die haben schon entsprechend gewirkt. Wir blicken noch ganz kurz nach Indien, was dort die Finanzministerin tut. Das war eigentlich als ein großes Thema vorgesehen im offiziellen Podcast. In der normalen Episode ist aber dann durch Putin nicht realisierbar gewesen. Dann schauen wir noch nach Tunesien und wie Flüchtlinge, die sozialen Medien brauchen, gebrauchen, missbrauchen für ihre Flucht. Und wir gehen zu Ikea nach Wien. Da ist nämlich alles anders, als man sich das sonst bei Ikea vorstellt.
Gibt es keinen Kuiplolach oder was?
Das gibt es sehr wohl, aber es gibt zum Beispiel keine Parkplätze.
Man muss sich alles liefern lassen. Das nimmt so viel Stress raus. Das ist so gut. Ich lass mir sowieso alles liefern, was in diesem Maße, weil alles andere ist so ein Stress. Da muss man mal in den sauren Apfel beißen. Sehr gut. Wir lesen meinerseits Mark Schieritz Buch über Olaf Scholz, unseren Kanzler. Scholz galt als ein Mann von gestern, über den man eigentlich nichts wissen wollte. Zitat aus dem Buch. Dann war doch alles irgendwie anders, denn plötzlich war er Kanzler. Und jetzt, gerade jetzt interessiert uns ja, wie tickt dieser Typ? Und ich finde, Mark Schieritz hat auch einiges rausgefunden und für uns so herbeianalysiert, wo wir uns die ganze Zeit fragen, ist das jetzt schon Verherrlichung? Steckt das echt da drin oder und so weiter? Fragen wir uns dann gemeinsam. In Hessen wird der Herr Ministerpräsident abgelöst im Mai. Und ausgetauscht gegen ein Zögling. Und in der Frankfurter Rundschau ist ein Text erschienen, der, finde ich, sprachlich mal angemessen damit umgeht, mit was für einem Scheiß wir es hier an der CDU Hessen zu tun haben. Das werden wir dann wortwörtlich vorlesen. Eine sehr lange Chronologie in der FAZ zur Kehrtwende. Was passiert da eigentlich wirklich, als Olaf 5 Uhr morgens aus dem Schlaf gerissen wurde und plötzlich bis 2 Uhr nachts in Brüssel verhandeln musste? Und schon klar war, am Samstag, am Sonntag gebe ich eine Regierungserklärung ab, wem sage ich vorher Bescheid und nicht und so. Da kann man mal auf Lücken. Ich finde, sowohl der deutsche Journalismus als auch die deutsche Politik ist da gerade so ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, es ist auch ein bisschen Glück dabei so insgesamt. Und ja, Adam Toos, der schreibt ja jetzt irgendwie jeden Tag über die Ukraine-Krise. Und dieses Chartbook 91. Was wäre, wenn sich das russische Regime oder Putins War-Regime, wie er es nennt, für MMT jetzt entscheiden würde? Was haben die eigentlich bisher gemacht? Es ist, wie soll man sagen, wir sehen ja in Friedenszeiten auch immer auf so schäuble Finanzpolitik und denken uns, was für ein Scheiß. Und hier wird es ja wirklich mal jetzt auf die Probe gestellt. Jetzt geht es mal um was bei diesem Vergleich eines Wirtschaftssystems mit dem anderen. Und naja, wie das bei Adam Toos so ist, da geht es ordentlich zur Sache. So sieht es aus.
Wir wollen noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass man den Salon buchen kann, beziehungsweise ich muss anders anfangen. Wir bekommen immer mal wieder über Twitter oder sonst wie Fragen. Ja, aber wie komme ich denn in den Salon? Also in den Salon bekommt man kommt man über Steady. Und das kann man am besten aufrufen über die Homepage dieses Podcasts. Also Neue Zwanziger. Das ist, glaube ich, der einfachste Weg. Und jetzt eröffnest du uns aber noch einen ganz neuen Weg, wie das noch einfacher möglich ist, zumindest für jene, die mit Apple-Geräten zu tun haben. Du musst es erklären, ich verstehe es natürlich alles nicht.
Heute als Experiment, eigentlich wollten wir es ja so einfach wie möglich halten. Steady macht es uns super easy. Allerdings kann man ja auch mal die Hörer denken, für die es vielleicht auch einfacher wollen. Apple bietet ja seit einer Weile an, dass man dort einfach einzelne Bezahlfolgen in den normalen Stream reinhaut und da ja der Salon in dem normalen Zwanziger Stream stattfinden kann. Nur wir dann wollen, dass man da kurz die Paywall überspringt. Das Angebot macht Apple und ich versuche das heute mal durchzugehen. Also wundert euch nicht, wenn heute spät noch im normalen, falls ihr mit der Podcast App auf dem iPhone die Podcast hört, da die Folge nochmal auftaucht. Wenn ihr schon Salonmitglieder seid, ist das genau dieselbe Folge, die ihr in eurem Salon-Feed schon habt. Muss man also nicht doppelt anklicken, sieht man auch im Cover und so weiter. Aber für alle, die eben noch nicht abonniert sind, die könnten dann mit einem Klick, so ist das Versprechen, mit einem Klick bezahlen und hören.
Und bei den sind es zwei Klicks und dann kann man sich ein bisschen loslösen von dem amerikanischen Großkonzern. Ja, je nach Geschmack. Aber wir wissen natürlich aus eigener Erfahrung, dass Bequemlichkeit manchmal verführerisch ist. Ich ertaffe mich ja selbst auch immer wieder dabei, wie man dann sagt, ach ja, aber jetzt noch mal extra anmelden, dann doch lieber über den einen, diesen Bezahlbutton oder so. Wir werden sehen, wir gucken, ob das funktioniert. Und da würde ich sagen, dann sehen wir uns jetzt gleich im Salon.
Genau. Und diesmal, wir haben noch zwei Autokommentare offen. Einmal Niklas, der uns ausführlicher berichtet. Das hängen wir dann an. Und Simon hat noch eine Frage. Der hat auch unsere Grabber Berichterstattung gehört und stellt uns noch mal eine Frage. Die klären wir dann auch im Salon. In der Hinsicht herzlich willkommen für alle, die hier kommentieren wollen. Im Salon besprechen wir auch die Kommentare, die zum Beispiel zu der allgemeinen großen Besprechung, also des Monatsende-Podcasts dann anfallen. Gut, dann bis gleich im Salon. Tschüss.